there is no such thing as a very fine
neo-nazi
i would agree with you yeah i would
agree let me ask you this would it
change your opinion
if trump agrees with you and he had said
that at that exact same conference
oh it would have helped
you know this election coming up there
have been a lot of accusations of racism
and it struck me that a lot of people
still believe president donald trump did
not condemn white supremacy
in charlottesville north carolina where
peaceful protesters were protesting
racial injustice
and then on the other side there were
neo-nazis
the commander-in-chief said there were
fine people
on both sides that's what he says
they're moral equivalents they're
good people on both sides no one wants
to hear from the man
who says there are very fine people on
both sides
essentially suggesting that there are
very fine people in the nazis
something no president's ever ever said
so they're very
fine people on both sides i realized
there was no video actually questioning
people about this it didn't exist
so i decided to make one myself but i
had to go in
in disguise
let me ask you do you think that donald
trump has has he done enough to condemn
white supremacy
no you don't think so no
so personally i i don't think so do you
think that
donald trump has done enough to condemn
white supremacy
i mean it's kind of a trick question if
you ask me okay sorry well just the
point that he's always
at least not speaking up uh very clearly
in condemning some groups right i think
it's pretty clear when you look at
comments like can you condemn david duke
and there's a hesitation and two week or
a week or two later he responds with
yes i condemn it well you think he
hasn't been he hasn't been as clear as
he needs to be
in my opinion no do you think that
donald trump is a racist oh absolutely
okay and what makes you uh say that i
listen to every word he says
every word every word because of a lot
of the things that he said
um just throughout all of his speeches
especially in context to the coronavirus
calling it the
china virus and things such as that like
it's
yeah just you know i just don't think
that he really
like mexicans he hates mexicans there
hasn't been
a unilateral like on every single front
that white supremacy is bad from donald
trump there's been hesitations there's
been missteps very consistently and i
think that's what's opening the door for
a very
uh unfortunately racist base so
like charlotte's feel like an example
find people on both sides yeah i mean i
think
that was to me was kind of a
unnecessary comment and i think just
knowing how
if you're so against the media then why
give them something to look for
right why not just say clearly yeah
white supremacists they should be
condemned totally yeah exactly and
i think once that's said then
then i think that's just to me it's an
easy thing to do right
what bothered you most about his
comments on charlottesville
oh the good people on both sides okay it
should be pretty easy
to condemn white supremacy neo-nazis
outright in no uncertain terms david
duke should be a very easy person to
disagree with
right or condemning white supremacists
or neo-nazis in charlottesville
yeah right you would have and you would
have liked to see both of those yes
to make sure we're talking about the
same thing this was this was
charlottesville right you have the first
uh this is the yeah play it this is the
one that we are talking about right
[Music]
good people on both sides and you had
some very bad people in that group
but you also had people that were
very fine people on both sides right
and yeah i wish he would have that is
one of the moments there is no such
thing as a very fine
neo-nazi i would agree with you yeah i
would agree let me ask you this
would it change your opinion if trump
agrees with you
and he had said that at that exact same
conference
oh it would have helped would your
opinion of him be different if he had
done those things
and that would be better condemning not
really it wouldn't change my mind
really yeah okay well he's saying it now
because he knows he's in trouble well no
he's been saying it for a very long time
have you seen the full clip you're
changing culture
and you had people and i'm not talking
about the neo-nazis and the white
nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
but you had many people in that group
other than neo-nazis and white
nationalists okay
does that change your opinion on maybe
have you seen that before today
uh i think i have i don't remember the
last part
right where you condemned white
supremacy did you know about that full
context before you saw that clip
i haven't seen the full clip does that
help like you said
you know it helps but it goes on and on
and on
like i don't think that has a big
influence on my opinion one because
like i said like those two comments
aren't the only parts it's been a very
consistent part of his rhetoric but do
you think with charlottesville do you
think i was dishonest with the media to
say he didn't condemn white supremacy
when he did at that certain instance yes
um no i don't think it was dishonest i
think they were just pulling from an
actual thing that he said out of his
mouth
but what you're reading and what you
watched you never actually heard or saw
the comments of donald trump condemning
white supremacy at charlottesville
no i didn't see it yeah i did see that
did you know about that full context
before you saw that clip
i haven't seen the full clip i i'd seen
the clips and that's why
i told you whenever you first
interviewed me or the start of this
interview
is my thoughts on that and i think that
he can do more i think the media is
biased in that way like
obviously that's not what's gonna get
used on cnn does it worry you that
that's the first time you're seeing that
considering i've seen that before oh but
you said that he didn't would it change
your opinion
if trump agrees with you and he had said
that at that exact same conference
oh it would have helped i i listened to
the strength of what
he says but you didn't know until just
now that he said i'm not talking about
white supremacists or neo-nazis who
should be condemned totally
and you just said that had he condemned
it in no uncertain terms
you would have viewed him differently i
don't think i don't think i view him
differently
like from that he hasn't done enough in
general in general yeah i mean
i think just there's been other
instances that you can really i know
you're
talking specifically about that clip
right let me go doesn't change your
opinion though
no and i mean he says there are fine
people on both sides what about david
duke
sure david duke and robocalls are out
again the white supremacist movement
supporting you
do you have any words for that well i
disavow david duke endorse me okay
all right i disavow okay when we looked
at it and looked at the question
i disavowed david so are you prepared
right now to make a clear and
unequivocal statement renouncing the
support of
all white supremacists of course i am of
course i am
when goes on for about nine minutes the
exact same question i said i disavow
i just about then i disavowed today on
abc with george stephanopoulos i
disavowed again
eight minutes so it might grow redundant
but you can tell me when you think it's
enough
i mean i think yeah i think that's an
episode over the years i totally disavow
the klu klux klan i totally disavow
david duke ultimately he got to the
flute luxe land which obviously i'm
going to disavow i reject
david duke rejected david duke i've
rejected
the kkk i think i get the point of the
video
so we went through charlottesville and
he said in general um i mean it could be
a
it could be a two-hour video does that
change your opinion again at all on his
in outright condemning and no uncertain
terms white supremacy
um no i mean i'm not saying that donald
trump is the president of like white
supremacy i think he just could have
done more
well again it's the inconsistency that's
been like the open door for
uh white supremacist and right
nationalist and neo-nazis to support him
does that change maybe your
opinion on donald trump's view there
no no it doesn't so you don't care so
much about what he said
no no no what what would be required for
you to say that he's adequately
condemned them
it it's it's a good point you make and
it's it's it's a
it's a matter of degree of strength but
it's a good point you make i think you
watch that clip for the first time and
you could have said
you know what i still don't like donald
trump but that changes the context
i think that would have been a better
answer but instead you argued that he
still hadn't done enough and so i just
agree with you i think he's done enough
i thank you looking down white supremacy
and now i'm embarrassed that i got into
this with me
are you doing social differencing yeah
is that larry david look is it larry
david
hey angela doesn't look like larry david
from a distance right there
hey there youtube viewer if you like
this video click one of these other
videos playing in a box
subscribe hit the notification bell you
may be wondering why after this
outlandish video this is such a straight
end card that's because we've recently
learned that end cards actually
determine the youtube algorithm as it
relates to controversy on a sliding
scale
so we have a yellow and it escalates
all the way to the word